bien ahora vamos a ver la manera en la
que el reproductor de dvd funciona y
bueno primero hay un disco giratorio
justo aquí
este voy a suponer que es nuestro dvd y
bueno el gira alrededor y debajo de él
hay un motor y ese motor gira lo que
provoca que el disco gira y después hay
un lente y bueno por acá hay un
reflector y por acá hay un diodo láser y
el diodo láser emite una luz en el
reflector que pasa a través del lente y
se enfoca en el dvd y toda esta parte de
aquí se va desplazando hacia fuera
mientras el dvd gira y lo que sucede es
que el dvd refleja la luz de vuelta
hasta acá donde hay un recolector de luz
el recolector de luz dice bien eso es un
hoyo o una protuberancia y mandan esa
información vía pulsos de electricidad
de vuelta al microprocesador
ahora veremos el ensamblado de láser
comprende un número de partes como bueno
por acá tenemos el diodo láser una serie
de reflectores tiene un lente tiene un
láser o sensor de luz y tiene un
mecanismo de ajuste y lo primero que
haremos será quitar esta cubierta que ya
había aflojado un poco para que fuera
más fácil quitarla y pueden ver justo
aquí hay dos imanes de neodimio creo que
es neodimio porque son bastante fuertes
para su tamaño pienso en un imán de
tierras raras y bueno lo importante es
que suelen ser imanes permanentes y muy
muy muy potentes y justo aquí pueden ver
que hay dos en bobina dos de cobre aquí
y dos embobinados de cobre acá y el
lente está montado entre estos cables y
puede desplazarse y moverse y sospecho
que ese mecanismo permite los ajustes de
sintonía fina del lente
muy bien ahora vamos a ver si podemos
quitar este reproductor de dvd y para
eso voy a sacar este prisma de kim este
sensor recoge la luz reflejada y la
envía de vuelta y bueno veamos si puedo
veamos si puedo quitar esta parte de
aquí que es importante
bien aquí está aquí está el diodo láser
y este es el pequeño amigo que emite la
luz la luz del láser que pega en el
disco se refleja y es leída por este
sensor